foreign
Industries and transforming the way we
will leave and work it encompasses a
wide range of Technologies including
machine learning deep learning natural
language processing computer vision and
many more with its ability to analyze
vast amount of data and make Intelligent
Decisions AI has become a game changer
across various domains hi everyone
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
this AI roadmap guides you in navigating
the path towards building a successful
career in artificial intelligence the
ultimate goal of artificial intelligence
is to create intelligent missions that
can perform complex tasks exhibit
human-like intelligence and contribute
positivity to society AI presents
exciting career opportunity in various
Industries and sectors roles like AI
engineer data scientists NLP Engineers
computer vision Engineers AI research
scientists robotic engineers and many
more offer exciting prospects for
working with cutting ITS Technologies
and making an impact through artificial
intelligence Innovation according to
last year the average reported salary of
an AI engineer in the United States is
around 105 000 per year however in India
it is still like per annum leading
companies worldwide are fully aware of
the immense value of AI and are actively
pursuing skilled AI Engineers to
contribute to their research development
and implementations of AI technology
among this
as top companies are Google Microsoft
Amazon Goldman Sachs apple and JPMorgan
Chase therefore top companies hiring AI
engineer provide excellent opportunity
for aspiring professionals on that note
eliminate your career with our Ai and ml
course developed in partnership with
Purdue University and IBM gain expertise
in high demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning charge GPT
generative Ai explainable Ai and more
Unleash Your Potential and unlock
exciting opportunity in the world of AI
and ml this course cover tools like
python tensorflow Keras charge apt open
AI gym matplotlib and many more so hurry
up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details our
Learners have experienced huge success
in their careers listen to their
experience find the simply learn course
reviews Link in the description box
without any further delay let's dive
into the topic now if you decide to
become an AI engineer here are the steps
you can follow to achieve your goal
firstly obtain a strong foundation in
mathematics and programming gain a
strong foundation in creating mathematic
Concepts like linear algebra calculus
and probability theory in addition to
that it is crucial to occur Mastery of a
programming languages like python
commonly used in Ai and become
proficient in coding then earn a degree
in a relevant field that means earn a
bachelor's or master degree in computer
science data science AI or a related
field to gain a comprehensive
understanding of AI principles and
techniques next gain knowledge in
machine learning and deep learning to
become a AI engineer develop similarity
with ML algorithms neural networks and
deep learning Frameworks examples
tensorflow by torch to train and
optimize models using real-world data
set followed by that work on practical
projects gain hands-on experience and
showcase your skills by working on AI
projects moreover will a portfolio of
projects demonstrating your ability to
solve of EI problems embracing potential
employers then stay updated with the
latest advancements stay updated with
the latest trends and research in AI a
rapidly involving field and expanding
your knowledge by reading research
papers participating in online courses
and workshops and joining AI communities
next collaborate and network engage with
AI communities attend conference
participate in online forums to connect
with Professionals in this field
collaborating with others can enhance
your learning experience and open new
opportunities later seek internships or
entry-level positions gain practical
experience through AI internships or
entry-level roles in industry or
research institutions this provides
valuable exposures and help develop your
skills finally continuously learn and
adapt in the rapidly involving field of
AI stay updated on new developments
explore specialized areas and embrace
emerging Technologies and tools to
pursue a career as an AI engineer now
that we have covered the s extension
steps to become an AI engineer let's
explore the necessary programming
languages and algorithms for aspiring AI
Engineers so mastering programming
languages like python are Java and C
plus plus is vital for occurring
Proficiency in AI this language is
enables you to construct a deploy models
effectively additionally it would help
if you gain a thorough understanding of
machine learning algorithms such as
linear regressions K nearest neighbors
name base and support Vector missions
these languages and algorithms are
fundamental tools in the field of AI
they will enable you to develop and
Implement effective artificial
intelligence models now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced huge success in their
career we need to keep updating your
skills the course material was
comprehensive and the faculty was
extremely experienced The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep up Skilling for every working
professional stay relevant continue
learning with this we have come to the
end of this artificial intelligence
roadmap in 2023 I hope this video was
informative and interesting if you have
any queries regarding topics covered in
this video or need help opening for this
course please let us know in the comment
section below our team of experts will
happily resolve all your queries as soon
as possible until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here